في احتفاله بذكرى مرور 200 عام على فك
العالم الفرنسي جيم فرانسوا شامبو رموزه
حجري رشيد اختاروا المعهد الثقفي الفرنسي
احياء المناسبه عبر اقامه معرض لطلاب
المدرسه الفرنسيه بالقاهره المعارض يضم
اعمالك لفنون الخط والكتابه والتصميم تحت
اسم يوم علم المصريهات السنه دي اشتغلنا
كثير على مئويه تحت فكر رموز حجر رشيد
الحجر كان بمساعده مصري زي الراهب يوحنا
شفتشي الرهيب كبير لانه هو اللي علم اللي
هو الابطال شامبو
كثير ان هو يفهم النصوص اللي هي كانت مش
مفهومه على حاجه الرشيد
اسات الفرنسيه حول تاريخيه الحدث واكتشاف
علم المصريات يعني بيشرح بطريقه مبسطه
كيفيه اكتشاف حاجه الرشيد
واهميته ومكانه وكده معلومات عن حاجه
الرشيد بشكل عام وبعدين الطريقه المعلومات
عن حياه شامبوليون بشكل عام الطريقه اللي
اشتغل بها وازاي مراحل اكتشافه للفك
الرموز الهيروغليفيه وبعدين ازاي همم
اكتشاف ده اسس لعلم المصريات بيحس به
مسؤولينا فان للمعرض اهداف اخرى تحقق رؤيه
مصر في البحث العلمي
باهداف تنميه المستدامه ورؤيه مصر 20 30
والتشجيع على البحث العلمي والشرف اللي
كان عندنا مليون لغايه ما قدر ان هو يحل
او يفك رموز حجر رشيد وده الشغب في اللي
عايزينه نوصله للاولاد انه دائما يجري
وراء الهدف بتاعه الخاص بيه ويبقى عنده
اشتغل في انه يقدر يوصل يعني
في معرفه اسرار الكتابه المصريه القديمه
من حيث بنيتها اللغويه وتركيبها الصوتي
استحواذ جهود شامبو على الاهتمام الفرنسي
والعالمي طوال هذه الفتره وتسليط الضوء
على انجازه العلمي المهم في تاريخ مصر
القديمه بين ان القصه بدات قبل هذا تاريخ
بما يزيد على 20 عاما بعد ان اكتشف ضابط
فرنسي حجر رشيد في قلعه قايتباي واستشعر
اهميته لكن التاريخ اغفل ذكره طوال ما
يزيده على 200 عام